welcome back this is the Ben Shapiro
show we're taking your calls at eight
five five at two three six at thirty two
twenty eight eight five five two three
six thirty two twenty eight Trevor and
Delaware you're on Ben Shapiro show go
forever hey then - del or just wanted to
say I'm a really big fan and um I'm a
good analyst for a company that
Elizabeth Warren danced and so I I
really appreciate your kind eyes
data-driven approach to um kind of
tackling a lot of the political issues
of the day so my question is at this
point is it worth it
I'm really not a fan of doing business
based on politics I think it should be
separate but is it worth it at this
point to organize some sort of town or
boycott against businesses I give in to
the less demands the censer free speech
like on Facebook I mean it's kind of I
mean we're how long yeah yeah no I mean
you're you're I think that's exactly
right I mean I think I think that as
I've discussed before what we basically
have on our hands - prisoner's dilemma
so the worst case scenario is what is
happening right now which is that the
left boycotts companies and pushes them
to basically become leftist mouthpieces
and the right does nothing and the best
case scenario would be everybody leaves
everybody alone but that's not happening
and the second worst case scenario is
probably that we all boycott everybody
because at least maybe there's the
possibility that with mutually assured
destruction corporations either learned
that these boycotts are ineffective or
corporations simply cave to everybody
and then we have councilor corporations
that are right-wing in nature I think
the latter is probably the most likely
to happen I think that there will be a
right-wing coffee company like black
raffle coffee and there will be a
left-wing coffee company like Starbucks
I think there will be a right-wing razor
company and a left-wing razor company I
think that well we'll end up happening
is the complete fragmentation of our
corporate or a corporate culture because
of corporate cowardice but I I agree
with you listen I used to run a group
called truth revolts we explicitly said
at truth revolt that we were the anti
Media Matters and our goal was to go
after
advertisers and use exactly media
matters as tactics on the left and the
same way they used it on the right so we
went after Al Sharpton for example we
went after his advertisers and we asked
them to cancel their advertisements
based on the fact that al Sharpton is a
grifter and not only a grifter a race
baiter who's been involved
not one but two race riots right who and
and we got a couple of advertisers to
cancel we were responsible probably for
Alec Baldwin being kicked off the air
because after Alec Baldwin Newsday aides
an anti-gay slur we went to advertisers
and said you want to be on Alec Baldwin
we said openly we don't want to do any
of this we said openly we're not
interested in doing any of this but the
left does this all the time and so
either corporations are going to learn
to endure themselves to the advances of
predatory interest groups or we are
going to make it impossible for the left
operate either everybody gets to operate
in a free reign in a free space of ideas
where corporations are not targeted or
nobody does and I think that we're
quickly reaching that point because
right now the left is clever they're not
just going after advertisers on right
wing programs they're going after the
social media companies and what's
happening right now where do you have
companies basically pulling their cash
from entire social media platforms to
get the social media platforms who
changed their rules such that people who
disagree with the left are branded
racist and kicked off the platform so
far the social media companies have been
fairly careful about who they have
kicked off I don't think they've been
completely careful I think there's some
really egregious cases they kicked off a
feminist named Megan Murphy for
suggesting that men are not women and
that's been happening on Twitter more
and more often
but overall they've basically been
picking outlier cases where it's very
difficult to defend the person I think
over time the lessons gonna push more
and more it'll be people like me and
Mark Levin and Sean Hannity and Rush
Limbaugh on the chopping block right
that'll be the goal and the and they
won't be going after talk radio it will
be going after the social media
platforms they'll be suggesting that
social media platforms ban people like
you for having your viewpoint so if if
corporations don't feel the pressure
from the right like if you go along with
this then you're gonna lose the other
half of your constituency and they're
just gonna cave to the left because they
always understand the right is gonna be
good and and they're going to to not
provide any sort of real ramification
for for them for the corporation
swinging left's like we're not going to
boycott Nike per se but the left will
boycott left will be loud and so just as
a matter of as a matter of due course
they will move on they'll move in that
direction so I agree with you I agree
with you Trevor I mean we may be in that
place at this point yeah we don't get to
the point where it's fragmented like
that but at this point I'm not sure if
there's an alternative hopefully I'm not
sure it'll either
it's sad it's sad it shouldn't be like
this
I mean it's gotten to the point where as
I've said before uh you know I got
ripped online for this but what I
thought was a pretty obvious point which
is if you have a sports league that is
pushing only one side of a political
message and then you have another sports
league that is pushing a completely
different side you might end up with
fragmented audiences if you have a sport
that says we're at we're a sport that
honors the American flag and the cops
that's gonna be one group of people and
then there's gonna be a sport that
paints black lives matter on the side of
the court
not just because everyone in America
believes black lives matter but because
the implication is that they're a bunch
of Americans who are deeply racist and
that the system itself is racist and it
makes a broader argument and and that's
gonna fragment viewership so I guess
that's the way we're going as a country
and that means that we will be
culturally pulls apart Trevor appreciate
the call some are in Prince George of
Virginia go for it summer hi I had a
question so my cousin is a gay liberal
and as far as I know he's always voted
on that side of the spectrum I'm a
conservative we have a very open
relationship and conversation both of us
respect each other's ideas but we often
don't agree on things for the most part
something we do agree on are the recent
riots and protests we don't agree with
them and how they're being carried out
the looting the burning of buildings so
on and so forth I do want to talk to my
cousin about voting of you know this
year when it comes to the President and
I know he plans on both voting for Biden
how would I approach in your opinion the
the conversation to kind of sway him to
vote for Trump even though I know he
very much dislike the president and a
lot of his policies I feel if he votes
for Biden he is going to be voting for
these protesters he's going to be voting
for the demands that they are making and
this is something he has told me he
clearly does not want so how do you
think I should approach the conversation
in trying to convince him that if she
does vote for Biden he is voting for
these radical views I think that you
have to point and this is a problem with
Biden you have two points politicians
Ivan Biden so Biden did condemn the
rioting and the looting he did it three
days later but he's late and he's slow
and he doesn't
really fight against any of this stuff
but he gives the impression of somebody
who is not per se going to going to
stand for the looting and the rioting
you can point out that the Obama
administration did I mean they did stand
for the looting in the rioting they kind
of rooted for it in Ferguson and
Washington DC but it's hard to say it's
hard to paint Joe Biden as a super
threatening guy who's fine with rioting
and looting when he occasionally says a
thing and also doesn't appear
particularly threatening said that is an
inherent problem you'd be much better
off if the candidate were like Bernie
Sanders who's burning would be out there
like actually weeding the erection of
guillotines at chubbies houses property
it would be better for Trump if you're
running against somebody like the Kamala
Harris
who has expressed that this is just sort
of the the outrage of the moment and
that looting and rioting our expression
of legitimate American outrage about the
racism of the system because Biden is
not alive it's very difficult to say to
people Biden is dangerous
the to cut and the two messages are in
conflict right Trump has been trying to
push two one is Biden is senile and the
other is Biden is a threats your
freedoms they are actually both true
right he has seen island because he is
senile he is not gonna be running the
party but that's a that's a hard message
to push all I can say is that the
Democratic Party overall has been a lot
more Tyler I mean Jenny zerkin is a
perfect example
very very tolerant of an incredibly in
actual quasi terror state set up in the
middle of Seattle and she's just been
sitting on it for weeks so saying that
that Biden you know would be much more
like any Durkin than he is likely to be
like any of the Republican governors who
prohibit this sort of stuff that seems
fairly common sensical now whether your
cousin goes for it or not is another
story but it's again it's it's Biden
makes it difficult Biden's a tough
candidate needs a tough candidate
specifically because he is so kind of
inoffensive Uncle Joe not radical
doesn't make he's not making huge
mistakes he's not he's actually he's
actually running a pretty good campaign
I mean all the circumstances have also
collided to make this an easy campaign
for him because if you were forced to be
out on the road all the time I'm not
sure that he could stand it like it's as
though God basically said how could I
create an ideal campaign for Joe Biden I
know I'll restrict everyone in America
to their basements so it doesn't look
weird when he's just sitting in his
basement and also I will make it so that
he only has to speak once every four
days and also he only has to make the
most anodyne statements about the most
common sensical things ever like don't
rip down
George Washington and who will appear to
be moderate right well I do worry to
whoever he takes us his vice-president
yep I do feel like there's going to be a
point in time where that person takes
over the presidency because Joe Biden
will eventually go brain-dead or this
will be totally incompetent can't make
decision so I worry if he picked
somebody that's very radical and
believes in this new movement that's
going on that they will in turn go ahead
and make policies and laws based off of
the demands of these crazy writers yeah
no I mean I think that's right I think
that you're almost gonna have to wait
until he selects a VP because once you
select a VP then yeah that is going to
be a target right if it's Elizabeth
Warren for example there's a lot to
attack about Elizabeth Warren if it's
common law Harris there's a lot to
attack about common law Harris if it's
Joe Biden you are almost literally
beating a dead horse and and so there's
not much you can do that I appreciate
the call summer and hang in there take
more of your calls in just a moment
eight five five two three six
32:28 Mason in Washington DC you're on
the bench Shapiro shop go for it Mason
hey Ben how are you doing this is he
really excited to speak you all so a
quick question for you so I as a stupid
person myself um I have no it's funny
and I talk a little bit more bit like we
can move back and forth of ethnicity
race religion and now it's like well
that world world right whenever someone
ever goodness happy hard work you know
where a bad in time now is I'm ignoring
how do we and I find myself not even one
even together see the people I have the
even same I'm a person of color
I'm checking other and putting Jewish
down boxes just to feel like I'm you
know how do you think this dangerous
good like how do you think we order this
you can be identify and erase how did
what you're doing on that so Jews are
both a race and they're really an
ethnicity and and a religion the one I
care about is the religious aspect of it
because frankly I don't care about
whether you have a a Jewish ancestor or
not the typical accordingly the only
reason excuse me the only reason that
matters in any real way for Judaism is
because it's a matrilineal descent
religion so you don't have to convert in
if your mom was Jewish right if your mom
was Jewish then you already assumed to
be Jewish and that's just the way that
the descent works but the idea that this
confers some sort of you know
knowledge is a great irritant to me and
it's one of my chief bugaboos right I
really really despise when you'll see
Jews who have a Jewish mom or Jewish
parents and then they will hate Israel
it'll hate the Torah he'll hate religion
they'll hate all of that stuff leftism
is their religion they'll be like but as
a Jew it's like well you haven't I'm
sorry nope nope nope nope nope that is
not how any of that works now as far as
the idea that Judea that Jews are viewed
as a Relais are viewed as it as a race
on the intersectional hierarchy the
answer there is yes because Jews have
been treated as an outsider group on the
basis of ethnicity before so Jews have
been treated as a group in the United
States they were banned from higher
education in many areas of the United
States throughout the 1920s and 1930s
there were signs in stores in the United
States saying no Jews allowed that
existed in the 1920s in the 1930s in the
United States there was widespread
discrimination against Jews not the only
ethnic group right I mean in the early
20th century there were signs saying no
Irish for some people but Jews had it a
lot later and a lot more harshly in the
United States then the Irish did as a
general matter so if you're talking
about just victimized groups in world
history Jews are a victimized group in
world history so it depends on the
purpose of the conversation if the
purpose of the conversation is does your
Judaism matter and the religious aspect
matters if the purpose of the
conversation is were you labeled to Jew
for purposes of discussing whether you
are part of a victimized group yes Jews
are the single most victimized group in
America in terms of hate crimes on a per
capita basis and it is not particularly
close so it matters in that sense so
both of those senses matter the left has
decided that Jews are not in victimized
group because Jews are
disproportionately successful
economically speaking so it doesn't
matter that the number one targets hate
crimes it doesn't matter they experience
disproportionate hatred against them as
a group they don't count because they
are well educated and earn a lot of
money in the United States that's not by
the way exclusive to Jews you see this
with Asian Americans to Asian Americans
are now in the white category Wesley
yang discusses this in his book the the
souls of yellow folk he's a New York
Times bestselling author his book he
talks specifically about the idea that
Asians are now considered sort of white
because they were a quote-unquote model
minority so really what the Left does is
they create a hierarchy of victimhood
and victimhood can be gauged by just how
much your economic indicators lagged by
group instead of looking at you as an
individual that's the way the left does
it so if we're gonna look by group and
our victimized group historically
speaking but I would never say that the
Jews are victims of systemic
anti-semitism in the United States today
because that's an insane contention but
I never found myself looking at my own
selves in partisan group I just doesn't
you know whatever until the left started
putting up all the or more so I was a
little group so do we continue do I
continue or do people continue to
identify as in group or do we just break
out of it and just not you know like
we're not gonna confined to these groups
um I mean I think that again identifying
as as religiously Jewish is the one that
I care about uh but identifying as a
member of a racial group is really I
think generally pointless unless it has
a religious connotation again if you are
identifying as my mom is Jewish
therefore I don't have to convert you
know that that is a different thing than
I'm identifying as jewish therefore
grant me special favors as a jew like
that that i don't tend to agree with so
i appreciate the call mason will take
more of your calls in a moment at eight
five five to thirty six thirty to twenty
eight eight five five to thirty six
thirty to twenty eight you're listening
to the bench pero show this video is
sponsored by bling sell it is the
revolutionary invoicing software for
small businesses spend less time billing
more time making the money with bling
sale go down to the link in our
description and give it a click